is micah parsons underrated mike are you
ready we're good here here we go
oh
[Music]
hey we're testing them man nice hips
micah
[Music]
welcome to underrated the only show
dedicated to improving the video game
ratings of professional athletes today
micah parsons if god built a linebacker
it's this kid penn state dallas cowboys
the only thing brighter than his future
is this jacket
my guy micah parsons the man in real
life but what about in madden let's go
to our pro gamer yo boy pizza
thanks a lot adam now look we got micah
parsons probably the best defensive
prospect coming out of the entire draft
this man has skills all over the field
he's a speedster he has the acceleration
but one thing that i was taking a look
at is his man coverage i feel like they
did him a little bit dirty with that
rating
[Music]
so i have some of your ratings
this is your day job man coverage what
do you think that rating is see i'm
gonna go for 75
59.
you want me to hold that for you are you
going to spike it or something
that has made me sick to my stomach
let's bring in
my guy
the official madden ratings adjuster
clint oldenburg
[Music]
i thought man coverage was low yeah at
59. i do too
because when he was coming out all i
heard during the draft was he can stay
with anybody now you're a great athlete
undoubtedly
you're 17th already among all middle
linebackers and man coverage you're
right behind devon white dante hightower
two great nfl players so you're already
inside the top 20 now but i think we can
help today okay
[Music]
how are we going to do man coverage i
think we're going to get a little help
from one of our friends kyle pitts is
going to be controlling a robot for us
he's strutting in like ric flair
styling profiling
limousine riding he's gonna run routes
with this robot and you're gonna cover
the robot okay
micah your job if you choose to accept
it is to stay with this dummy as long as
possible on my count three two
one go
oh that's past interference
come on kid
i think he was all over it yeah that's
the flag coach that's a flag i don't
know that was pretty good coverage three
two one go get out of here kid
hey you lost come on bring it back
another rep we'll beat you again
three two one go
come on kyle
is that you good all right here's the
last one
three two one go
[Music]
you lost
i don't know he was kind of there
the ball's out we have to be practical
it's inside leverage kyle you should
know better
clint what were you able to glean from
this exercise
with this guy did see some some quick
feet that athleticism that we talked
about
what was it at before was that 59 so 59
what are we going up to uh you're gonna
get a plus two you're gonna go up to 61.
that puts you in the top 15 among all
middle linebackers in the nfl now we
need to fix that one thing
catching
we got micah parsons who is just an
all-around athlete we all know that and
his hands is catching showing up at a 57
rating look we all know you got to be
able to catch the ball as a linebacker
if the ball is coming to you you don't
want to be that guy that messes up and
right now with a 57 rating i feel like
he'll be dropping balls more than he
actually would in real life do you have
hands
i do have hands what do you think your
catching rating is i'm gonna say like a
75
your catching is 57
i i can't tell if you're laughing
because you're happy or if you're just
this shocked or that's just atrocious
atrocious atrocious egregious egregious
and atrocious
a linebacker with hands is a
surprisingly great part of a defense you
know what else is surprisingly great the
rates at state farm that fit any budget
[Music]
i want your rating to go so high that
people don't even recognize you so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to bring in
a dude with a golden arm
jordan love let's bring them in wow yes
sir
see that
that's the future right there okay we're
going to have you run some classic
linebacker drills and i don't want the
balls to be easy to catch not because i
want him to fail but because if he makes
the big catch what happens clint rating
goes up how much does it go up i think
we got a nice range of maybe six to
eight points
let's go get it remember drops hurt
that's okay you got to go big or go home
warmer
hey let's do this here we go
let's go
okay easy finger tips
second ball set
micah drops back goes deep comes in hard
left
oh
he throws good zipping yeah that almost
flipped through his hands there
what's that
come on oh harlow
there's a good one hey
he's staring right at you hey
i see it he's staring right that close
oh no you see it
what do you need more from him can can
we get him to flip his hips and see if
he can make a catch over his shoulder
okay going deep yeah okay okay cool yeah
all right let's do that let's do that
[Music]
no drops can we give him a low one okay
deep or you know come down here either
one okay cool i'll bring him downhill
how are we feeling micah
big time born right he's eating out here
good he's getting real cut this one i'm
a little bit worried about
he's dropping he's coming in
there was some cool
air nose up
he caught it we tested him man we tested
him
impressive performance i think the best
one was the one he had to reach out for
over here on the right side yeah and he
caught it yes
yes so i think there's some room uh to
improve this rating
micah how much points do you think you
earned on your catch rating i said
between five to eight when i was
guaranteed
i mean that was what was offered to him
yeah yeah you're gonna get an increase
of eight
to your catching rating so you're now
gonna be a 65
that moves you up
this is how close it is at the middle
linebacker position you're moving from
101st ranked middle linebacker all the
way up into the top 35.
what we witnessed today
was born ready micah parsons stepping up
and handling his business
man coverage went up too
catching went up eight
and so clint i really have one simple
question that i want you to look right
into his face and answer is micah
parsons underrated yeah coming into
today we have michael parsons underrated
you fixed some of those concerns we
talked about from catching college
congratulations thank you colin
i think that's what life's all about
baby
you